drink up darling
I hate whiskey but it's all that was
left
I keep trying to get your mom's banana
she will give me her mom phone number I
love dogs they're like the best thing in
the world and I was happy I never had a
dog my parents that does before they had
me
the dogs were on purpose I was a mistake
[Laughter]
[Applause]
don't give up no they can't keep coming
hey this really happening I can't
comprehend father the mother in here I
can't what a guy give those puppies
c'mere
are they adoptable if you want a friend
for life then you should just get a dog
they just they need a home and you can
give them one like look at this and out
and look at this dog did you see that
she just like me I'm a puppy okay thank
you says he Allison T I had bunnies
bigger than this my bunnies would eat
you but they're dead remember when you
guys just kept bringing dogs in here
that was so crazy
hi we made a series it's coming on
November 18 please watch it get it here
yeah yeah you gotta see it it'll be
released 2015 November okay